-Il rêvait de devenir footballeur.
Il a fini député
après avoir été journaliste sportif,
puis maire.
Mon invité aime relever toujours
de nouveaux défis,
un peu à l'image
d'un sportif de haut niveau.
Générique
...
Bonjour, Karl Olive.
-Bonjour.
-Il y a une constante
chez le journaliste sportif
et l'homme politique :
vous aimez le show,
faire le spectacle.
On va voir
que ça remonte à loin.
*-Je suis étudiant
en communication.
*-En communication.
*-C'est un confrère.
*-J'aime l'imitation.
Il imite Alain Decaux.
*-Bonsoir. En 1789,
Vincent Perrault n'était pas né.
Pourtant, Pierre Bonte,
fidèle à lui-même,
cherchait déjà la France,
car il savait,
chers téléspectateurs,
que 200 ans après, il serait là,
face à la caméra,
prêt à bondir.
*-Je te file ma place ou...
On échange ?
Très bien.
-Ca, c'était en 1989,
sur FR 3,
magnifique imitation
d'Alain Decaux.
On l'a reconnu.
Vous étiez étudiant
en communication,
et vous avez fait
une trentaine de jeux télé.
Vous aviez une idée précise.
-L'idée, c'est exactement
ce que vous venez de voir,
c'était pas de gagner
des machines à laver,
des séjours, des voyages,
c'était faire un métier public.
Il se trouve
qu'à la fin de cette journée,
Michel Péricard,
qui était un des invités
de l'émission,
me propose de devenir pigiste
d'une télévision locale,
qui allait naître,
Yvelines Première.
J'ai démarré le 18 décembre 1989.
Forcément, ces moments-là,
vous les oubliez pas.
Je suis devenu directeur
de cette télévision en 1994.
-Cette stratégie
vous a permis de mettre un pied
dans le milieu de la télé,
jusqu'à devenir
patron des sports de Canal+.
Ce qui est marrant,
c'est que vous n'avez pas changé.
L'homme politique que vous êtes
fait pareil.
Vous aimez vous mettre en scène
sur les réseaux sociaux,
avec votre petit footing,
qui se termine
par un message politique.
Vous postez ça sur Twitter.
Après chaque adoption de loi aussi,
vous vous filmez, comme ici,
dans la cour d'honneur,
pour parler de la loi
que vous avez votée.
Est-ce que vous n'en faites pas
un peu trop ?
-Ce que je sais,
c'est qu'en 2014,
lorsque j'ai été élu
maire de Poissy,
l'idée que je ressentais du terrain,
c'était de dire
que les hommes politiques,
une fois élus,
ils bougent plus.
Moi, je suis parti
sur l'idée du miroir et du service.
Miroir : ce que nous faisons.
Service : améliorer
le quotidien des administrés.
Il y a le savoir-faire...
-Ca prend pas le pas sur l'action ?
-Il faut pas être toujours
là-dedans.
J'ai la faiblesse de penser
que si je suis réélu
en 2020 avec 75 % au premier tour,
c'est pas seulement
de la communication.
Quand vous êtes
dans l'engagement local,
il faut aimer les gens,
et ça ne s'apprend pas
dans le dictionnaire
ou à travers les images.
-C'est l'autre trait qui ressort
de votre personnalité.
Dans votre carrière
de journaliste
ou dans celle de politique,
vous êtes à l'aise
partout, avec n'importe qui,
dans n'importe quel milieu social.
C'est un don qui est quand même
très utile en politique.
-Je crois qu'il vient de l'éducation
que j'ai pu avoir avec mes parents.
Ma maman avait perdu les siens
à 3 ans et 5 ans.
On était huit dans la famille,
donc, vous êtes toujours
à la 1re personne du pluriel,
pas au singulier.
Quand vous êtes huit
autour d'une table,
qui est presque une table de ferme,
que votre papa a fait 42 ans
chez Simca-Chrysler,
vous savez ce que c'est,
la mobilité sociale verticale,
que la mixité sociale,
et ça, j'aime beaucoup.
Il faut surtout pas que ça change.
Sinon, on perdrait son âme.
-Ce don vous a permis
de vous faire beaucoup d'amis
et souvent bien placés,
dans tous les milieux : de la télé,
des patrons de chaînes
ou des personnalités
comme Michel Denisot,
dans le milieu du sport,
plein de footballeurs, de rugbymen,
de judokas, avec David Douillet,
qui a joué un rôle important
dans votre carrière,
au tout début,
des patrons :
Henri Lachmann,
Claude Bébéar.
Vous êtes un homme de réseau.
Parfois, c'est connoté négativement,
mais vous l'assumez,
d'être un homme de réseau ?
-J'assume le fait
d'être celui que vous avez indiqué,
d'être sans contrôle,
sans a priori, sans état d'âme.
On voit Claude Bébéar à l'écran,
je dis souvent que les plus grands
sont les plus simples. C'est vrai.
Ca fait quelques années
que nous nous connaissons.
-Moi, j'étais chez iTELE
quand vous étiez
patron des sports.
-Exactement. J'ai un profond respect
pour toutes celles et ceux
que je croise.
J'adore, le matin,
une à deux fois par semaine,
prendre mon café
avec les éboueurs.
J'ai autant de plaisir à faire cela
sans aucun jugement.
Je pense que ça nous permet
de rester en adéquation
avec la réalité du terrain.
-Vous avez fait une rencontre
très importante, en 2014,
vous étiez tout juste élu
maire de Poissy.
Une rencontre qui s'est faite
dans des circonstances
assez étonnantes.
*"Crocodile Rock", Elton John
*...
C'était pas Elton John,
mais c'est directement lié.
Racontez-nous ?
-D'abord, Elton John,
c'est un monstre de la musique.
-Vous êtes passionné de chansons.
-Oui, tout à fait.
Il se trouve que j'étais à Bercy
avec Claude Bébéar,
parce qu'il sait que j'aime
la musique, avec mon épouse,
et qui voyons-nous arriver ?
Un jeune ministre de l'Economie
qui avait été nommé
2 jours auparavant, Emmanuel Macron.
On s'est retrouvés à chanter,
à danser sur Elton John,
avec madame Macron,
mon épouse, et là encore,
je me suis pas demandé
si c'était le ministre
de l'Economie,
il s'est pas demandé
si j'étais le jeune maire de Poissy.
En revanche, on s'est bien marrés
à chanter sur Elton John,
"Sorry Seems To Be
"The Hardest Word", par exemple.
-C'est le début de votre relation
avec le couple Macron.
Comment vous décririez
cette relation
que vous avez avec lui ?
C'est de la politique,
de l'amitié, un peu des deux ?
-Franchement, le président Macron
est un homme vrai,
celui qui met ses actes
en face de ses mots.
Il m'arrive de l'appeler
pour lui dire :
"Vous devriez appeler
"l'arbitre de la finale
de la Coupe du Monde de rugby,
"qui est, 1re dans l'histoire
"d'une Coupe du Monde,
arbitrée par un Français."
"Merde, je l'ai pas fait,
trouve-moi son numéro."
On a des relations particulières,
mais simples.
-Pendant la crise des gilets jaunes,
Emmanuel Macron vous a fait venir
avec un groupe d'élus...
-Non.
Il ne m'a pas fait venir à l'Elysée.
J'ai dit au président :
"Les réformes
"que vous voulez mettre en place,
les Français les ont comprises,
"mais la manière de faire
est catastrophique.
"Je vous propose
"que vous veniez nous voir ici,
à Poissy, pendant deux heures,
"ça va pas vous plaire,
mais ça va vous rendre service.
"Tu vas en prendre plein la gueule."
Il m'a dit : "Banco."
Sauf que c'est le jour
au Puy-en-Velay
où il y a l'incendie
d'une préfecture,
où ça s'était mal passé.
-Ca a été délocalisé.
-Exactement.
-On vous voit ici face à lui
avec d'autres élus des Yvelines.
-Avec Génération Terrain.
-Vous avez tenu
un langage assez cash
pour qu'il comprenne la réalité ?
-On lui a dit qu'il fallait
venir sentir le cul des vaches,
comme on dit en Bretagne,
descendre sur le terrain.
Au sortir de cette réunion,
quelques semaines après,
il y a le grand débat
qui se met en place,
et le sentiment que nous avions,
et je connais le président,
entre 2017 et 2019,
le sentiment que j'avais,
c'est qu'il y avait une déconnexion
entre les décisions prises,
"je décide, vous exécutez".
-Vous teniez à ce lien
avec le terrain,
mais vous l'avez perdu
en renonçant à votre écharpe
de maire pour devenir député,
et tout cela était lié
au non-cumul des mandats. Du coup,
à peine élu,
vous rédigez une proposition de loi
pour changer les règles.
*-C'est dommage,
c'est l'ancien maire qui parle...
Oui, il y a en effet
ces fantassins de la République,
en prise avec le terrain,
qui sont plébiscités
par les Français,
qui ne font plus partie du tout,
de fait, des deux chambres.
*-Macron vous a écouté ?
*-Il est très bienveillant.
Il est très bienveillant.
-Une majorité de députés
était d'accord avec vous.
Emmanuel Macron lui-même.
Le problème,
c'est que votre proposition de loi,
elle a été enterrée
par vos collègues de la majorité.
Ca vous a surpris, déçu ?
-Non,
c'est le cheminement normal.
Je pouvais comprendre
que les collègues,
élus sur une promesse
de non-retour au cumul...
La vérité, c'est que c'est
une vaste hypocrisie.
-Vous étiez d'accord.
-Mon petit doigt me dit
que dans la réforme
des institutions,
ça reviendra.
Il suffit d'écouter
Stéphane Séjourné,
il y a quelques semaines.
C'est important.
On est passé de 250 députés
dans l'hémicycle en 2012
à 0, aujourd'hui.
Il y a un juste milieu.
-Des députés-maires.
-Des députés-maires, bien sûr.
Il y a un équilibre à trouver
par rapport à cela.
On peut être, aujourd'hui,
député et conseiller départemental,
député et conseiller régional,
on pourrait pas être maire et député
sans être à l'exécutif ?
C'est une hypocrisie.
La France en a besoin.
La France a besoin
d'un souffle de terrain.
-Sur ça,
cette proposition de loi enterrée,
est-ce que ce n'est pas frustrant ?
Vous découvrez ce qu'est un député,
par rapport à un maire,
qui peut agir
et prendre des décisions seul.
-Ah ben oui,
on est 100 % exécutif,
PDG, c'est pas vraiment le mot,
et on passe à auto-entrepreneur,
à l'Assemblée.
On a un rôle de législateur,
mais quand je propose une loi
sur le gaspillage, transpartisane,
aux collègues LR,
- transpartisane,
lutte contre le gaspillage,
qui doit transcender les bancs -,
et on me dit non,
parce que ça vient de la majorité.
Toute votre vie,
vous parlez du pays,
mais y en a que pour votre parti.
-C'est l'heure de notre quiz,
à présent,
pour voir quelle sorte de député
vous êtes.
Je vais commencer une phrase
et vous allez la compléter.
C'est bon pour vous ?
"Etre député,
"c'est comme au foot..."
-"C'est toujours tenter",
"même si on ne réussit pas."
-Pas de jeu collectif ?
"A chaque fois
"que je vois un député sans cravate
dans l'hémicycle..."
"-Ca me donne des boutons."
-Vraiment ?
-Pas sans cravate,
mais quelqu'un qui arrive presque
en jean troué,
à côté des huissiers,
des administrateurs de l'Assemblée,
qui sont toujours très élégants...
C'est pas un concours d'élégance,
mais on représente...
-Une question de respect ?
-La représentation nationale,
c'est quelque chose.
Etre député de la nation,
Je suis fier de mon pays.
On doit l'incarner
au plus haut niveau.
-"Beaucoup me voient
devenir ministre,
"le souci, c'est que..."
-"C'est pas une science."
Le fruit tombera quand il sera mûr.
S'il tombe pas...
Je suis le plus heureux du monde.
-On sent que vous avez toujours
eu besoin de bouger.
A chaque stade,
vous aviez un autre objectif.
Ministre, ça peut en être un ?
-C'est pas une fin en soi.
Si on peut être utile...
-Si vous devenez ministre un jour,
vous continuerez
à présenter vos voeux ?
*"Les divorcés", Michel Delpech
*-On pourra dans les premiers temps
Donner l'info aux habitants
-Ca, c'est les voeux
que vous avez présentés,
en député,
au 1er janvier.
Vous avez quand même choisi
une chanson un peu triste, non ?
"Les divorcés".
Pour raconter un peu
le passage difficile
de maire à député ?
Vous êtes malheureux ?
-Non, c'est un bilan, que je fais.
C'était plus facile
avec "Les divorcés"
sur ses allitérations
et ses vers en 8 pieds
que sur La Bande à Basile...
Vous voyez ?
-Vous êtes triste ?
Vous êtes heureux, à l'Assemblée ?
-C'est ce que je dis
dans la chanson,
il faut aussi mastiquer,
façonner le fait,
effectivement, d'avoir eu à gérer
un village dans lequel vous êtes né,
avec 850 agents
et 105 millions d'euros de budget
au fait de devenir député,
un 577e
de l'Assemblée,
mais c'est formidable.
C'est un bel engagement.
-Merci beaucoup,
d'être venu vous confier
dans "La politique et moi".
*-C'est arrivé un paquet de fois
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Si on manquait de quoi qu'ce soit
Il y a toujours le 49.3
Qu'Elisabeth peut dégainer
On ne veut pas en arriver là
L'opposition fait tout pour ça
Et la majo doit avancer